we talked yesterday about chick-fil-a's
cave to the LGBT rage mob and I pointed
out as many others pointed out as well
that the cave on top of being cowardly
and shameful is also pointless and
counterproductive it's not going to
accomplish anything from a pragmatic or
business perspective because it only has
the potential to alienate their current
base of customers and it's not going to
appease their critics or create new
customers so there's really nothing in
it for them and now that certain gay
groups have offered their official
reactions over the last couple of days
to this news about LG trick filets
surrender to them I think my point has
been totally confirmed so I want to go
through a few of these here there's
definitely a lesson in this for all of
us that we can all learn here's I
referenced this yesterday but here's the
actual statement from GLAAD Gay and
Lesbian Alliance Against Defamation in
addition to refraining from financially
supporting anti LGBTQ organizations
chick-fil-a still lacks policies to
ensure safe workplaces for LGBTQ
employees and should unequivocally speak
out against the LGBTQ reputation that
their brand represents so translation
there number one they want chick-fil-a
to come out and it's not enough to just
stop donating to quote anti LGBTQ
organizations which by the way that's
the Salvation Army a group that helps
the poor provides toys for kids around
Christmastime it that's that's anti gay
in the in the minds of the people over
at GLAAD but they need on top of that
they need chick-fil-a to come out and
actually explicitly denounce Christian
teaching on gay marriage denounce
they're you know they're their founders
and they're their CEOs position on it
that's what they need and then in terms
of policies to ensure a safe workplace
for LGBTQ employees that of course is
just nonsense there's there's no
indication no hint no evidence at all
that chick-fil-a has discriminated
against gay employees or provided an
unsafe environment for gay employees and
that's what's been the the absurdity all
along with this is that chick-fil-a
hires and employs gay people
they don't discriminate there they serve
gay people has never been any
discrimination at all but GLAAD is so
what they're doing here is they're not
only giving additional it demands but
they're also slandering and smearing
chick-fil-a on top of it that's their
way of saying thank you is to smear them
and then the Human Rights Coalition says
while this is an important step for
chick-fil-a the company still does not
have workplace protections and policies
that are fully inclusive of LGBTQ people
it's according to Beck Bailey of the HRC
foundation we look forward to the day
when chick-fil-a's commitment to
welcoming all is reflected in their
workplace policies and practices by
including explicit sexual orientation
and gender identity non-discrimination
protections meanwhile you've got the
website LGBTQ nation with the headline
remember chick-fil-a isn't LGBTQ
friendly yet and the website The
Advocate says
chick-fil-a still is an LGBTQ friendly
despite pledge on donations okay and
it's just a handful of examples but this
shows you this is the response okay so
and you've got you got this response
from from the left and from the gay
groups attacking chick-fil-a and now
you've got conservatives and Christians
criticizing chick-fil-a so they've just
they just pissed everybody off and the
latest isil's are already sort of
flip-flopping and the president of
chick-fil-a came out and said well we
still haven't totally made up our mind
actually we still haven't totally and
maybe we'll still donate to the
Salvation Army we'll see I'm
paraphrasing slightly but so now they're
scrambling and the thing is if they
backtrack and say now never mind we're
it worked we're still gonna donate it's
it's too late they've just this was such
a horrendous mistake this is the classic
unforced error everything was going fine
for chick-fil-a everything was going
swimmingly it was splendid over at
chick-fil-a
they were growing they were serving
chicken everybody whatever you know most
people love them then you got this small
group of Fringe people that we're
complaining about them but in fact it
was kind of nice having them because
those people was just more publicity and
the kept chick-fil-a in the headlines
and you know galvanized support behind
Chiclets
they chick-fil-a really had the ideal
situation for
you know a restaurant chain really when
you think about it because great product
great service great reputation as far as
that goes lots of support growing and it
but then also having that little core of
people always attacking them is kind of
good because like I said it galvanizes
support it creates headlines that's what
they had now it's just it's all it's all
ruined and what you have to understand
what we have to understand is how the
left operates in the culture war we're
seeing in here they are like Sherman's
march to the sea in the Civil War burn
everything down make sure every house is
destroyed
every field is smoldering the enemy is
the enemy so give them no quarter no
respite do not accept surrender right or
at least unconditional surrender and as
always you contrast that with the other
side you contrast that with the
opposition and a strategy for years on
the other side has been well maybe if we
show how reasonable we are maybe you
know maybe they'll go easy on us then
maybe if we concede a little ground here
and a little ground over there
and okay a little more ground here and a
little more ground there and and maybe
now they're happy okay they're not happy
so well just a little bit more well
we'll just back up a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more until
you've just backed up and they've pushed
you over the cliff into the sea it's
it's completely pathetic
certain point I don't know at a certain
point you think P ones gonna learn their
lesson and understand how this works and
a thing for chick-fil-a is and this is
really the truth it it honestly does not
matter what they do they could even do
the donation thing no more donations
they could they could come out with a
statement condemning Christians and and
disavowing and just complete and total
surrender they could do that and it's
that still wouldn't be enough I
guarantee you because the you know the
gay lobby and the left they're not ever
gonna forget or forgive because of what
happened in the past I mean think about
the left going and tearing down statues
of people that lived two hundred years
ago or five hundred years ago centuries
could pass and they're still not gonna
forgive you it could be five it could be
five you'll be five hundred years in the
future okay we could be we could be
looking at like the Year 2500 and and
chick-fil-a has has you know long sense
disavowed and everything and they still
still would be persona non grata as far
as the left is concerned
speaking of shameful compromises I've
got a doozy of one to talk about next
but but first before we do that I want
to tell you about paint your life you
know I sent paint your life a picture
one of my favorite pictures of the kids
at the lake last summer when we were on
vacation and they sent me back this
beautiful watercolor rendition of it my
wife and I loved it
displayed now proudly in our living room
and there's something about the painting
as a as opposed to you know the
photograph photograph is great but the
painting it really brings something out
of it really really turns the picture in
into a moment you know from a moment
that was captured into a work of art and
and that's what I love about it if you
want to give a truly meaningful gift
the holidays either a gift to someone
else or to yourself into your own family
you've got to try paint your life calm
have an original painting of yourself
your children family special place
cherish pet done for you at a price you
can afford from paint your life come and
I want to say prices are great also the
turnaround time is I was really
impressed with that they I I thought you
know you send in the the picture and I
felt like six months later they'll send
you in a paint thing no no they they
sent it back very quickly but not like
it's rushed it's beautifully done so if
you look at you would think they spent
six months doing it this is a true
painting done by hand by a world-class
artist created from a favorite photo
makes the perfect holiday holiday gifts
also great for birthdays anniversaries
weddings and right now is a limited time
offer you get 30% off your painting
that's right 30% off it's a huge
discount free shipping to get this
special offer text Matt 264 thousand
that's Matt ma TT 264 thousand texts ma
TT 264 thousand okay now I want to play
something for you and this this is not
hyperbole I'm not being dramatic the
video that I want to play is very
upsetting it's infuriating and let me
give you the set up first thanks as
always to LifeSite news for their great
work on this and for bringing it to my
attention let me read a little bit
actually from LifeSite news their
article on this it says provoking
concern among both parents and students
in Illinois school district voted last
week to allow gender-confused students
to choose which restrooms and locker
rooms reflect their gender identity the
board the board of district 211 voted
5-2 to last Thursday evening to adopt a
new policy for palentine high school
according to the Daily Herald it
declares that students shall be treated
and supported a manner consistent with
their gender identity which shall
include students having access to
restrooms and locker rooms that
correspond to their gender identity the
vote came at a meeting attended by
nearly 500 community members after the
school board rejected a proposal to let
the community vote on the question in a
district-wide referendum many of the
attendees vehemently disapproved of the
plan with one video in particular
starkly contrasting the Ben
fit two trans students with the fall out
for the majority okay now the video
referenced are you gonna see here are
two reactions to this insane vote by the
psychos over at this school board the
first is a boy gloating that now he gets
to change in the girls locker room
and the second is a girl a real actual
biological girl giving an honest
reaction to what is transpired and you
could tell that she is hurt she's scared
she feels betrayed she's got tears in
her eyes I do not know how any decent
person could watch the video I'm gonna
play for you and not feel sympathy for
the girl III really you'll see the boy
and then the girl I I don't know how you
could possibly watch this and feel more
sympathy for the boy than for the girl
but tell me what you think give us give
this a watch
I'm really hoping they vote for it it's
something gonna be a a step forward in
progress I'm I'm
really excited if they vote for it a bit
nervous though as as always just you
never know but it's definitely first
step forward in in many more steps it's
a great policy unfortunately it's not
everything we want such as talking about
even even the small things like changing
the name of your student ID which are
required to wear at all times so I'm
really hoping that the district makes
the right decision here in folks yeah I
passed it passed
and how does that make appeal I'm
ecstatic
I'm coming for my privacy premium baby
as I am I change multiple times okay
first of all I dare anyone to step up
and explain why that girl with tears in
her eyes terrified that she has to
change in front of a boy and you heard
her explain you know she's in swimming
so she's using a locker room she's
getting completely changed and and I
dare someone to explain why she's a
bigot why she's a bigot for wanting
privacy please someone send me an email
explain it to me spell it all out
because I want to hear it now second for
the sane among us what you see here is
the two competing claims very clearly
Illustrated we see the two sides
represented on one side you have a
biological boy dressed up like a girl
sort of who claims he has a right to
change with girls on the other side you
have a biological girl who claims she
has a right to privacy and to be
protected when she's in a vulnerable and
exposed State at school
okay now let's break this down let's say
that we say to the boy maybe let's
pretend that we're all sane and
reasonable and so we say the boy like we
should say you're out of luck sorry
you're not kidding what you want you're
just not getting it that's it now
change in a boys locker room that's
where you belong let's say that we said
that what's the downside
wait what is the worst-case scenario
what's the worst-case consequence or
something like that
the downside for him is that now he has
to change with boys because he is one
and he's being treated like every other
boy now that might make him
uncomfortable but it's a discomfort born
from his own confusion okay now what's
the downside on the other side what's
the downside to telling the girl she's
out of luck sorry we don't care you have
to get naked around a boy what's the
downside well she's now being deprived
of privacy she has to deal with the fear
and worry of having boys in the locker
room with her her safety is in jeopardy
her personal space and privacy is
obliterated I just don't see how any
sane person could look at this situation
the two competing claims and decide that
the downside for the boy is somehow
worse somehow more severe and in fact is
so terrible that it overrides the claims
of the girl that that's just absolute
madness but hang on a second because
this isn't just one boy verse one girl
this is one boy or maybe a few at most
in a whole school verse all of the girls
so what we're saying or what the school
board is saying rather is that the
comfort of these couple of boys
outweighs the privacy of every girl in
the school
so this bears repeating the claim here
is that the comfort of a few boys
outweighs the privacy concerns of every
single girl in that school that is just
look if you're if you're on board with
this
agreement with the school board there
are only two explanations as far as I
can tell either you're insane
or you're evil I just or II or you are
very very very stupid and you have
allowed yourself to be duped by the
leftist talking points on this so I'll
allow for that third possibility but
there really isn't there is not a
scenario there just isn't were a morally
decent sane intelligent person could say
that oh yeah I think that boy has a
right to change in the girls locker room
there just isn't and I eat you know and
that's and that's a broad brushstroke
and I'm and I'm using it that's a broad
a big huge paintbrush and I'm and I'm
yeah I'm painting the whole side that
way what I'm saying is of all the people
who are on this boys side saying he
should change it
every not a single one of those people
are intelligent morally decent and
saying not a single one now let me in
there there are some issues like that
and then that's why I let me head
something off of the past year I always
hear this whenever I talk about this
issue and when I speak in such strong
terms about it I always hear someone say
look man I'm not saying you're wrong but
it's complex it's it's a complex issue
it's very complicated and this is where
the stupid people come in this is this
is the stupid person response because
it's not complicated okay and I'm at the
point now where I'm a lot more annoyed
by the it's complicated people than I am
by the people who would just come flat
out and defend putting boys in the girls
locker room the ones who try to make it
conga it's nuanced it's complicated
maybe what annoys me is that they're so
stupid but they're trying to look
intelligent they're trying to they're
trying to come up with the you know sort
of rise above it I'm not on either side
you know I'm I see both and I see the
nuances and you just don't see it so
they're trying to take the intellectual
high ground even though they are so
enormous ly stupid this is not a
complicated issue there are complicated
things quantum physics is complicated
when it comes to moral issues a you know
an issue like capital punishment is
I would say complicated well you know a
complicated issue here's how you know a
moral issue is complicated if there are
intelligent and reasonable arguments on
both sides you know if you've got people
on both extreme ends of this discussion
making intelligent and reasonable points
then that's and then and then in between
on the spectrum bridging that gap there
are a bunch of intelligent reasonable
points - okay that's how you know you've
got a complicated issue on your hands
and something like capital punishment I
would say yeah I've heard really
intelligent and reasonable
points on both sides of it and all the
way in between this is not one of those
there aren't any intelligent or
reasonable points on the pro letting
boys into the girls locker room site
there just aren't there are none this is
so simple there's nothing complicated
about it at all
a boy says he wants to change their
girls locker room no you can't that's it
that's it that's all you have to say now
if you want to talk about an emotional
level as well don't you feel sorry for
these boys that are confused I'm the
first one to say that normally when we
talk about the gender thing and we talk
about gender confused people I'll be the
first to say that yeah I think we feel
compassion for people who have this
confusion that doesn't mean that we
compromise with them that doesn't mean
that we give up on reality that does
certainly doesn't mean that we succumb
to their delusion or we support them in
their delusion but yeah we can have
compassion usually but but here but
here's my thing the moment you demand as
a man or a boy to have access to a
girl's locker room and the moment that
you arrogantly narcissistically cruelly
say that their concerns don't matter you
know you can look at that girl you
people crying because they don't want
you in there because I feel
uncomfortable and you're looking at them
and saying that screw you I don't care
see the moment you do that I don't feel
sorry for you anymore
sorry I have no more compassion for you
I think you're just a bully and a jerk
and I think what you're doing and I and
I hold you also responsible why wouldn't
I
I mean you're responsible you you should
be a decent person putting the confusion
aside I understand that part of it but
you're looking at these girls you see
how uncomfortable how about just
worrying about them a little bit instead
of yourself how about how about not
putting yourself above everybody one
other point I want to make your
defenders of this madness will often say
oh come on do you really think a boy is
gonna pretend to be transgender so that
you can watch girls change in a locker
room do you think that's really gonna
happen now that's actually irrelevant
the point here is the privacy rights of
the girl the exact internal motivation
of the boy who invades the privacy of
the girl is basically irrelevant it
doesn't doesn't actually matter but
since we're on the subject do I think
that a boy would potentially pretend to
be transgender so that he could watch
girls change the locker room yes I do
that's it's certainly it's at least
possible if you're creating a scenario
where a biological boy has every right
to go into the girls locker room as long
as he's transgender but then also
there's no way to we just have to take
his word for it that he's transgender
it's not like there's any tests that can
be done there's nothing it's just we
gotta take his word for it he says he
identifies as a girl I mean it doesn't
matter if he if he came to school
yesterday as a boy and he was boy and
then a day later 12 hours later 24 hours
later he's saying he's a girl you have
to just cut you can't give yet you have
to take his word for it
so do I think it's possible that a boy
who is not gender confused would exploit
a scenario a situation such as that yes
it's possible in fact you can't deny
that it's possible you have to agree
with me that it is at least possible
right you can't say that it's impossible
is it impossible that a boy would a
biological a non gender confused boy
would exploit
no it's not impossible it is possible
right we have to agree on that it's at
least possible we could debate how
possible it or how likely it is what's
the degree of likelihood but forget
about that it is possible so here's my
point it's we're creating a scenario
where it's at least possible a boy could
exploit it to gain access to the girls
locker room everyone agrees it's
possible what you're saying if you agree
if you're on board with this what you're
saying is yeah it's possible but it's a
risk worth taking
so I just want you to say that out loud
that's all I just want you to say what
because that's your position that is
your position even if you're not saying
it out loud so I'm just that is your
position just say it out loud so that
you can hear yourself saying it I want
you to say yes I support a policy which
it would be possible for a boy to
exploit in order to invade the privacy
of girls and watch them change
but that's a risk I'm willing to take
just say that out loud
see how it feels when you say it out
loud in fact maybe you look in the
mirror while you say it so you can see
what kind of person you are who would
take a position like that in fact for me
put everything else that's the side even
though this isn't even the main point
because like I said the motivations of
the boys that's not even the main point
or even all that relevant but this is
enough right here that this should this
point right here should be enough that
is not a risk that I'm willing to take
or maybe I should phrase another way
that is not a risk that I think girls
should be forced to take because I'm not
taking the risk you're not taking it
it's it's the girls in the school and
it's our daughters generally in schools
across country we're forcing them to
take a risk and no I don't think they
should be forced to take it I don't and
if you do if you think they should then
yep look in the mirror and say that out
loud and see if you if you can really be
proud of yourself holding a position
like that all right before we move on
you know if you haven't been listening
to Andrew clavin's fantasy podcast
another Kingdom first of all then what
are you doing with your life if you
haven't been but you need to go to Daley
wire com subscribe right now to catch up
because on Monday November 25th at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific Andrew and
Michael Knowles will be sitting down
together to discuss the final season
also take subscriber questions live from
the fans this live event will be free
for everyone to watch on Facebook and
YouTube but only subscribers will be
able to ask the questions at daily
wire.com so and also by the way
subscribers exclusively can watch the
entirety of the series you can listen
free to the newest seasons on Apple
podcast go check it out now and don't
miss another Kingdom live discussion
happening Monday at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific all right what else well in
a similar vein to the last topic sprite
has a new ad out we'll cover this
quickly I've been I've had this on on
the docket to talk about for a few days
now so sprites they have a new a new a
doubt it's a sprite ad that that makes
no mention of sprite which
been the thing now in advertisements for
years of course I'm sure you've noticed
to have ads that just don't have
anything to do with the product at all
but not only does an I mentioned spray
but it doesn't even feature anyone
drinking a sprite I think from what I
noticed maybe I maybe I missed the shot
but I didn't even see someone drink a
sprite in the whole commercial anyway
that's not really the point the point is
that this ad is creepy as hell if you
haven't seen it give it a look
[Music]
when you are through a stone
hold your head
[Music]
be afraid of the dark
at the end
and of a store
there's a goal
sky
and the sweet
[Music]
[Music]
okay first of all can we just go back
quickly in freeze-frame it at 1:19 I
want you to look at though at minute 119
right here this is where the
cross-dressing guy heads to the gay
pride parade with his boyfriend and the
dad is looking on and I guess the dad is
supposed to seem proud or whatever but
but look at expression I think they
needed to reshoot that one because
that's not that's more of a like dammit
I screwed this one up didn't I look
isn't it that's not I don't really see
the the pride is that so we're like a
worried depressed look I just I think
that they I don't know they they
probably need to go back and do that one
over you can kind of tell that he's
thinking the dad's sort of thinking well
this really didn't work out how I
intended but anyway what you're seeing
here is is again the promotion and
propagation of confusion mental disorder
child abuse and it's being promoted and
propagated by a powerful force in our
society now I said this on Twitter few
days ago and there were leftists mocking
me for it a daily Coast rider among them
mocked me for calling sprite a powerful
force in our society now don't you love
it how these people they drop their evil
corporation shtick as soon as the
corporation starts singing their
ideological tune now all of a sudden the
idea that a corporation is a powerful
force is funny
so what are you talking about powerful
forces you spend all day ranting about
billionaires and millionaires and the
moment something someone responsible
with this corporation what they're doing
is well what do you care about
corporation doesn't matter now
sprite is owned by the coca-cola company
which is a multinational corporation
whose largest shareholder is Berkshire
Hathaway
so yes powerful force very powerful and
it is intent on promoting this we should
ask why
and we should ask what what is being
promoted here go back and look at the 17
mark 17 seconds what you're seeing there
is called breast binding this is the
practice of flattening a woman's breasts
to make her appear masculine of course
this is highly damaging physically to a
woman damage to the skin to the muscle
to the bone structure problems breathing
infections bacteria buildup all of these
and more are side effects obvious
inevitable side effects of trying to
crush a woman's breasts to make her look
like a boy now why would a woman or a
girl consent to such treatment well she
hates her female body and wishes that it
wasn't female and and and and and and
that's when she might want to damage it
in this way this is a form of
self-mutilation this is body dysmorphia
this is what people with anorexia have
where they they look at themselves and
they're obviously not overweight but
they feel like they're overweight they
look in the mirror and they see an
overweight person they don't like their
bodies and so they damage themselves
physically so and again it's similar to
what people who self mutilate suffer
from damaging the Babak body on purpose
now imagine a sprite Edie with
inspirational music slickly shot and
edited showing someone heroically
cutting themselves or purging after a
food binge imagine a campaign to accept
anorexia to stop the stigma against
anorexia not to stop the stigma against
anorexic people you know not to not to
have us accept anorexic people that's
different yes we should people who
suffer from this disorder we should
accept them we should be compassionate
towards them we should be sympathetic we
should want to help them so a campaign
like that would be fine I'm saying
imagine a campaign that says anorexia
itself is normal and fine and we should
accept it and celebrate it we would all
be horrified by that we'd condemn
whatever corporation produced that ad
we'd call them evil we'd accuse them of
trying to do great harm to children how
is this diff
it isn't the only difference is that the
delusion of the girl who chest binds is
politically acceptable ideologically
acceptable whereas the dilution of the
of the cutter or the bulimic is not
that's the only difference in all of
these cases though you have people
damaging themselves out of self-loathing
out of a rejection of their body a
rejection of themselves all of this
stuff these days and usually what you
get from from corporations and from
marketing campaigns especially when
things are geared towards women it's all
about accepting your body accepting
yourself for who you are you're
beautiful in all of that
well this ret runs directly counter to
that
because this what you're seeing depicted
in the commercial would be a girl female
who does not accept her body
and in rejects it so rather than saying
no except who you are
the ad is saying yeah well no go ahead
and that's yeah go ahead and do what you
have to destroy yourself
you
again horrific alright let's move on to
emails Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt
well show at gmail.com this is sector
this is from Dan says dear Matt did you
happen to see or hear about the latest
episode on the blacklist
on NBC I've watched on and off for a few
years but the latest episode was my last
the basic plotline of the episode was
that a woman was kidnapping conservative
men and impregnating them with what
turns out is her own rapist babies one
man actually gave birth to the baby in
the end the conservative governor that
apparently signed a late term abortion
bill in his own state was forced to
travel to New York for a late term
abortion of his own baby I could not
believe the lengths this episode went to
to propagandize abortion it really was
hard to get through and of course in the
end brave NBC failed to show the baby
being ripped apart and its head crushed
which would have been the only realistic
part of the entire episode just thought
I'd let you know about this ridiculous
show and thank you for speaking up about
abortion and faith issues I there's I
have so many questions
I mean how did she pregnant man what in
what way did he give birth I probably
don't want to know the answer to these
questions this is what they put on NBC
at what eight o'clock in the evening or
whenever blacklist airs yeah this is why
and and I mean network shows in general
are mostly just trash I'm putting it be
even putting aside the political
propaganda and the morally objectionable
content which is there's much there's a
lot of that but even putting that aside
my first problem with it was show like
the blacklist and I watched a few
episodes years ago I can't believe it's
still on TV just a bad show I don't know
how these networks are still getting
away with putting bad television on
there we live in the golden era of
television you've got you've got the HBO
and and and Netflix and Amazon and some
of the other did some cable and premium
channels just putting out beautiful
shows masterpieces and yet the networks
like NBC and CBS are still producing
garbage they're they're producing stuff
that would have been that would have
seemed bad in 1996 why do people watch
it you do know that Netflix exists right
I'm not saying everything Netflix puts
out is great but even even like the
worst show on Netflix quality wise is a
hundred times better than the best show
on NBC
anyway um that's not really the point
the point is the is the ideological bi
and this is this is why yet another
reason not to watch these network shows
and I think you're right to just stop
watching it why would you want to put
yourself through that and
this reminds me of what was that episode
I was a show on show called scandal few
years ago I don't know that was at an
end the NBC maybe I think was ABC ABC
show and they had their Christmas
episode a few years ago featured a woman
getting an abortion
while the song silent night played in
the background
so they're not trying to hide it they're
just putting it right out there for you
and what they're saying to you as the
viewer if you're a conservative if
you're pro-life what they're saying is
you are scum we hate you we don't want
you watching that's the message
this sounds like this blacklist episode
that's really the message to the viewer
saying if you're if you're not a radical
pro-abortion leftist we hate you despise
you don't want you to watch and so yes I
think we should respond to that and say
okay if you don't want us to watch we
won't this isn't even boycotting this is
just you clearly don't want ratings from
us and so we will oblige its you don't
want us to watch we want so I think
you're responding the right way to that
to that this is from Phil says hey Matt
a friend from high school used to be
conservative is now staunch liberal
hates everything Trump says and does
actually hosted a drag queen story hour
at the local library supports childhood
transgenderism etc he's been posting
lately about how non affirming
Christians are hurting the LGBTQ
community specifically those who
identify as transgender says that any
gospel interpretation that confronts
confronts it as sin or makes them feel
guilty about their choices is wrong and
should be condemned
he reasons that if we just affirmed
their choice then no transgender person
would commit suicide and this is more in
line with Jesus's teachings what are
your thoughts about this argument I did
not want anyone to take their own life
and I would never want to harm harm to
come to anyone but I do not agree with
this rationale his basic premise seems
to be that we change the Bible and
science so that people can live whatever
lifestyle they choose the there appear
to be no surrender no call for devotion
to God and His Holiness in his argument
it seems that he focuses only on the
love of God and none of God's other
attributes like wrath holiness
Redemption etc wanted to hear you say
got it
well I think what you said is exactly
right I would add two things number one
on the suicide argument it's of course
absurd to suggest that simply by
affirming biological truth we are
somehow causing people to commit suicide
that is emotional blackmail of the worst
and most cynical kind and also on the
suicide note it's just not true that
transgender people are committing
suicide at a higher rate because of
bullying that is not true it is true
that they're committing suicide at an
astronomically high rate their rate of
suicide attempts I think is somewhere
around 40 percent if I'm if I'm
remembering correctly it's something
something in that ballpark very
extremely high but what you find is in
any culture across the world no matter
if it's an affirming culture or not no
matter if it's progressive or
conservative the transgender suicide
rate remains extremely extremely high
so you cannot chalk it up to bullying if
it was all about that then what you
should find is that in a backwards
conservative culture quote unquote you
got the high suicide rate but then if
it's a more liberal place more liberal
culture if the suicide rate is back you
know around the the the average for
everybody else that's not what you find
also in fact you know I I think when you
look throughout history and you see
examples of actual persecuted minorities
such as you know the black community in
this country prior to prior to civil
rights or you know so many other
examples across the world in the cross
history you don't find you know among
black people in this country in Jim the
Jim Crow South their suicide rate was
not 40% I'm not sure that it was even
any higher than just the the national
average at that time in fact what you
find usually is that or oftentimes
persecuted minorities sometimes the
suicide rate goes down because there's
this effect of coming together and
resisting the oppression and and so you
actually find that sometimes
but what you don't find I'm not aware of
any other example of a persecuted
minority and transgender people are not
a persecuted minority in this country
but I'm for the sake of argument lumping
them in with that category I'm not aware
of any other example of a persecuted
minority with a suicide rate of 40%
why is that
that that's that's noticeable isn't it
doesn't that require an explanation
or are we gonna pretend that the quote
persecution of transgenders in 2020
nineteen American culture is worse then
what what black people went through and
say the Year 1905 and in Alabama are you
gonna really does anyone really going to
pretend that
I don't think you want to make that
claim
rate is so so so much higher why is that
you need an explanation that goes beyond
external factors like supposed bowling
and so on I think you have to look
inside internally and I think the reason
clearly is that these are people who are
struggling to accept themselves for who
they are and that is why we do have
compassion for them until they start
cruelly and arrogantly bullying others
and trying to victimize women then I
think at that point we draw the line and
say that's it sympathy is over because
now we're gonna be protecting these
girls over here and now I'm more
concerned about protecting the girls and
children than I am about your feelings
but as long as that's not happening yeah
we have compassion everything because of
this is what's going on internally and
that's what leads to the suicide rate
and this is exactly why we don't quote
affirm because that that this confusion
is what is causing their despair and so
when you affirm them in their despair
you are just causing on the plunge
deeper into the confusion which is the
source of the despair so that's how I
would respond to that let's see
this is from Matthew says according to
AOC cows are part of the climate change
problem using her logic or lack thereof
do you think her plans should now
include eliminating farting swall Wells
- that's a really important point I
didn't mentioned yesterday we were
talking about Eric sois whales
fart a live TV and I spent 10 minutes I
started my show I did start the show
with ten minutes of analyzing small well
farting and that's the kind of quality
content you get for me but yeah I think
looks whoa well melted an entire glacier
just with that one nuclear rectal blast
and so I think that if we're talking
about taxes on carbon emissions I think
he needs to be taxed for that I think
that there should be and I don't know
why a Oh see isn't stepping up to the
plate on this but if you think about how
much he himself just with that one fart
contributed to global warming now we
know that we have ten years left on
earth just with that one gaseous
explosion he's actually not two years
off of the lifespan of the earth now we
only have eight years and I think he
needs to be held accountable for that
so I'm total agreement with you and I
and I thank you for bringing up that
point and I think we'll leave it there
everybody thanks for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]